and especially if churches aren't
promoting submitting to the authority of
a man so this leads me um to an exchange
between
um
three content creators Brian from
whatever podcast Lila Rose and Ruslan
and I wanted to point out just a little
bit
what I think that the traditional
conservatives don't necessarily
understand so pull the clip
have you ever been in a situation where
you went to go split the bill at the end
and she was like I'm not paying half
no because I do some gangster what
do you do Brian all right here's what
that here's what you do first off first
off you should try to do something for
free
what yeah exactly
I got you Linda exactly what
you could do something for free right
definitely you don't do you never do a
dinner date dinner is terrible because
if it's you on the first date you want
to Quick out like if it's awkward or
it's not going well you don't want to be
sitting there waiting for your food like
that way so you maybe you go for a drink
or you go for a tea coffee right you go
to Starbucks now what you do is there's
a couple different options
if you don't even do the three thing
right
you just arrive early or you arrive on
time
and here's the thing like most of the
time women are late for days I'm just
saying I'm just saying women are
typically late for first days
so you can just arrive on time and just
she's gonna be 10 minutes late right
Adam you've been on first dates right
they're usually pretty low on average
probably more so more often than not um
so
you just get your drink you go to the
bar you get your drink then you go and
sit down and when she arrives you don't
walk up to the counter to help her get a
drink you're like oh I'm saving the
booth uh do you want to go and get
yourself you're not willing to buy a
girl 3.50 copy come on it's not about
the money it's not about the money it's
about the principle that she'll pay for
her own cup of coffee she will yeah so
she wants to know that you're down to
pay for it too it's fine though it's
fine the other thing is you could if
there's like a waiter that's going to
come bring a check again you get there
on time or early
she's gonna be late
and then you tell the waiter when you
bring the checks two two checks
at Starbucks
Brian I don't think you're going to meet
your future wife yeah
that's great this is great I've saved so
much money over the years being very
frugal that's the sexiest thing for most
women frugality by the way they love a
Frugal man but you may have saved money
but I feel like you probably would have
uh lost experience some more well but
you're trying to keep a low body count
right
where are you you might have met a
really cool girl who was just like
turned off by the not wanting to pay for
the coffee I went on a date with a guy
who was gonna pay the bill but then he
was asking how much a soda cost which is
like clearly the cheapest item on the
menu and that just turned me off and I
never saw the guy again it's not about
the money I know it's more about the
principle you know is this where we've
gotten to in dating in 2020 oh yeah
diabolical content look it's just not
pay for anything this this debate right
um Brian should men have to pay on the
first date
I agree with Brian you know I think
women we want to have both we're not
virgins anymore we have careers we make
our own money
um I I don't think men should have to
pay if they don't want to and it's so
interesting because the guys they're
under they're operating under is as if
the woman's the prize not him when guys
we've gone over this like the numbers
are just terrible when it comes to us as
a whole like a third of us have had an
abortion a third of us have had an STD
um 90 of bet on birth control we offer
like two kids maybe each
um so it you know I actually think if
more men operated like this I think
women would change but the issue is we
we make poor decisions and men just
continue to bail us out and it's so
interesting because Lila will shame the
man but she doesn't shame the woman and
I just I'm not gonna take I'm really not
gonna take
the church seriously until they start
calling out women for not waiting till
marriage and the reason I came to this
conclusion was I just started looking at
the numbers a guy that marries a virgin
has a 70 to 80 percent chance of a happy
marriage
70 to 80 percent chance if she slept
with five men which the consensus from
men is that most women on The Dating
Market has have
it drops down to 20 to 30 percent
20 to 30 percent so it's not as simple
as just pick the right woman and the
other thing the church doesn't take into
account is just how easily influenced
women are and the problem is we right
now we don't have churches that are
pushing women to completely submit to
the authority of men and if a guy tells
a chick to stop being friends with
someone or stop being on social media on
Instagram he doesn't have any authority
to say that and I think and that's
really my issue
um with the Trad cons right now is they
they don't acknowledge woman's true
nature which is women are very easily
influenced there's a reason that we go
with the latest fashion trends there's a
reason that politicians cater to us
there's a reason that we make 80 percent
of consumers buying decisions there's a
reason we don't make good life decisions
in general
think about this guys all we had to do
was wait till 22 to 25 be a virgin we
could go get like a Saudi billionaire
millionaire I mean and stay in shape
right and you got to be like semi-cute
but like honestly with how
with how bad the Western women are
that's all we had to do yet most women
will think only fans before they think
of that strategy what does that say
about women's decision making when one
out of 25 of us under the age of 35 are
on only fans
and you know I think it's a little bit
disingenuous to say take the risk when
there's a 75 chance of them failing so
there's a 50 divorce rate and then out
of the remaining 50 that's maybe a 50
chance the ones are happy and you know
it's funny
um they just say just find a good woman
in church but I'm sorry but the churches
nowadays have a bad reputation and the
what they'll do what church people will
do is they'll shame everybody else for
leaving the church and they'll shame men
for leaving the church instead of asking
why they left and the truth of the
matter is a lot of woke identity
politics is in church and churches
nowadays are catered to women you go in
and you see a band you see snacks juice
and and there's so many single women's
Ministries but they don't have that
level of marketing and Catering to men
they never demonize female sin in church
they only demonize male sin and you see
this when you see Purity speakers come
in and they allow women to come in and
blame their promiscuity on Brokenness
instead of a lack of character
you know again I would take it a lot
more seriously if they said it was a
lack of character and a lack of
discernment or or anything that would
take some accountability but what they
do is they have these Chastity speakers
come in and basically blame the men for
pressuring them into sex when the truth
of the matter is women these days if
they're not these pure innocent
creatures that we make them out to be
and you know we can't have both so if we
want traditional treatment then we have
to be traditional women and I'm sorry
for a lot of women that ship has sailed
it sailed it was it was in your 20s so a
30 year old lawyer yeah why the hell why
the hell does he have to pay
um and so then you know she goes into
again this is like what women do when
they want to shame men she'll say uh
you're not marrying the mother of your
child
well why don't we have the same shaming
for women you didn't wait for marriage
for the husband of your children but
I've seen Lila on different shows and
she's very soft with the women and you
know the the Trad cons and the right and
the left will label this as a good thing
you have to say it in a kind way for
women to hear you and the truth of the
matter is that is not true what evidence
do you have that's true because from
what I have seen women respond really
well to social shaming there is a reason
we had all of these systems in place for
all of history to shame female
promiscuity it was because women
responded to it
they responded to it but now the guy is
the bad guy for saying hey I'm going to
treat you like like you wanted to be
treated you wanted to be an equal so
here you are pay half and honestly guys
I I don't think it's that big of a deal
on a first date the next thing they
talked about was should churches Foster
marriage and until I see churches
demonized female sin the same way I see
them demonized male sin I I have a hard
time
buying into that because what I see is
them shaming men for having a porn
addiction but I never hear them shaming
women for not sleeping with their
husbands
um I think that's equally as bad if not
worse than a porn addiction
um and yet they'll kind of make it be
the same thing they act like a woman
having a high body count is the same
thing as a porn addiction when really if
you look at the numbers the high body
count is detrimental to society so
really what the churches should push I
swear if I was in the churches and if I
was in the churches this is what I would
do I would say hey guys hold out
put a lock down on marriage
yep hold out
let's get wait for the next generation
of women we are no longer accepting
non-virgins you know if the top men did
that in my opinion
the women would either lie better or
adapt
I better adapt this is this
I'm open to other other ideas guys but
my whole point is we cannot shame men
for adapting to the market that women
created if women created a market and
the men adapt that's on the fault of
women not men so if men don't want to
pay for dates anymore because women are
traditional why don't we shame the women
into becoming more traditional rather
than shaming the men and so this
mentality we see pushed in the media by
corporations and by social media
influencers so I want to give you guys
an example of pandering to women
another one so let's pull
the thing women it's like we kind of
admit our nature to ourselves because
there's two there's two things I noticed
here number one
she's automatically blaming the
environment right she's automatically
saying if the woman isn't growing
because let's be honest guys if a man is
broke we certainly do not blame the
environment we blame the man we say get
a job stop being a bomb we don't say ah
well
it's it's your mom or your teachers or
what you're scrolling through on
Instagram but if a woman makes poor
decisions we automatically blame what
the environment and the second thing
that I noticed is that this actually
just speaks the female nature and just
how easy we are to influence and you can
really see this because when they
implemented the right to vote a hundred
years ago and women got more say that's
when you see them putting all this media
messaging that women can do their own
thing it's like we had it so good we
could stay home with our kids we didn't
have to work and we chose to
we chose to be promiscuous we chose this
and you know what made us what made us
do that is it something innate in US
partially probably but it's also the
media the messaging
um corporations it's and it just shows
how men and women think because women
will make decisions oftentimes based on
who they surround themselves with where
men are more likely to make decisions
based on their beliefs and their values
there's a reason that we have phrases
like a man of his word it's not a woman
of her word because let's be honest you
can't and you can't trust us and I and I
don't say this you know I'm not saying
there aren't exceptions but I think we
have to look at common generalities and
to rule and Trends between the genders
in order to understand each other better
and you know she's even admitting um
when women are going down a wrong path
Instagram is to blame the people you're
around is to blame and you will act
different based on those things men it's
just not the same way even in voter
trends like uh propaganda and like media
campaigns work much better on women than
they do on men men tend to pick up pick
a party and stick to it
um but let me know what you guys think
in the comments maybe men and women are
exactly the same and women deserve to be
courted super traditionally or even
though we are not traditional women let
me know what you want me to cover
tomorrow like the video on your way out
subscribe to the channel and I'll talk
to you next time